can you maybe elaborate on
what is the role of cohesion and the
collective not to use that term but
multiple humans together connected
in the human condition sure i keep
getting the feeling that euron and i are
actually having an a disagreement about
empirical reality because i think that
enlightenment rationalist political
thought
features the individual
it features the state uh there isn't
really a nation other than the the
nation the people is as a collective is
created by the state and when the state
disappears then the collective
disappears now i think that when
conservatives
of all stripes
look at this kind of thinking that
there's the individuals and then there's
the state
and there really isn't anything else
when they look at that
they say
even before you get to consequences it's
a terrible theory because when we try to
understand any field of inquiry any
domain any subject area when you try to
understand it
we try to come up with a
a small number of uh of concepts
and of relations among the concepts
which is supposed to be able to to uh to
explain to illuminate
as much as possible
the important things they're taking
place in the domain
and conservatives look at this
individuals and the state and they say
you're missing most of what's going on
in politics
also in in in personal human relations
as well
but
it it just doesn't look like a
description of human beings it looks
like a completely artificial thing and
then conservatives say well look if i
want to adopt this artificial thing then
the consequences are horrific because
you're not describing reality
so a conservative reality uh begins with
um
with an empirical view of what you know
what are human beings like and and the
the first thing you notice about human
beings or at least the first thing i
think conservatives notice is that
they're sticky is that they clump they
turn into groups and you take any
arbitrary collection of
human beings and set them to a task or
even just leave them alone
and they they quickly form into groups
and those groups are always structured
as hierarchies this is this competition
within the hierarchy who's you know
who's going to be the leader who's going
to be number two but
there are everywhere you look in human
societies
universally
there are groups the groups compete and
they're high and they're structured
internally as hierarchies and then
they're internal competitions for who
leads the different groups
and when we think about scientific
explanation we allow that there are
there are different levels of
explanation
that you know a macroscopic object like
a table it doesn't have properties that
are that you know that can be directly
derived from the properties of you know
the atoms or the molecules or the the
microfibers that make up the table and
and and that's understood that there's
what you know uh academic philosophers
call emergent properties that when you
get up to the level of the table it has
properties like you know that you can't
put your fist through it which you can't
necessarily know just by looking at the
atoms alone
and i think conservatives say the same
thing is true for political theory for
social theory
that looking at an individual human
being and thinking about what does that
individual human being
need which euron does very eloquently in
his in his writings
but that doesn't tell you what the
characteristics are of this
hierarchically structured group as soon
as you have that it has its own
qualities so an example the question of
what holds these groups together and and
we need to answer that question uh
i i try to answer it by by saying
there's such a thing as mutual loyalty
mutual loyalty is shorthand for
human beings individuals have the
capacity to include another individual
within their self within within their
conception of their self when two people
do it
it it creates a
a bond like a like a bond between two
two atoms creates a molecule that
doesn't mean that they lose their
individuality they
within the group they they may still
continue competing with one another but
that doesn't mean that there isn't in
reality a bond and that real bond
is is the stuff of which uh political
events and political
history are made is the the coming
together the cohesion and the
dissolution of of of these bonded
loyalty groups that's the reality of of
politics
and so when i
hear these discussions about individuals
in the state
i feel like we're missing most of the
reality and in order to understand the
political reality
we need to understand
what makes human beings coherent to
groups what makes them dissolve what
makes the groups come apart and and end
up creating civil wars and that kind of
thing i think we also need to know um
what
in practice um rival groups do come
together and and bond i mean basically
when we think about uh democratic
society we're talking about different
different groups we can call them tribes
or you can come up with a different name
but but different different tribal
groupings with different views they come
together to form a nation
and they're able to do that even though
you know often they hate each other you
know like
like we were talking about the the
american revolution often they hate each
other and nevertheless they're able to
come together why how
and that leads us into questions like
how does
honor the giving of honor by one group
to another
how does that increase the uh
the mutual loyalty between groups that
that are still competing with one
another
all of these questions i think we have
to answer them in order to be able to
talk about politics and uh and and i i
think the reason the first reason why
why why one should approach politics as
a conservative rather than as an
individual is because it gives gives us
these these theoretical tools to be able
to talk about reality which we don't
have as long as we keep within the
individualist framework as as you're
talking the metaphor that's popping up
in my mind and this is also something
that bothers me with theoretical physics
the metaphor is there's some sense in
which there's things called theories of
everything we try to uh describe the
basic laws of physics how they interact
together and once you do you have a
sense that you understand all of reality
in in a sense you do and that to me when
you that to me is understanding the
individual like how the individual
behaves in this world but then you're
saying that they're hey hey you're also
forgetting chemistry biology how all of
that actually comes together the
stickiness
uh the stickiness of molecules and how
they build different systems and they
some systems can kill each other some
systems can flourish some can make
pancakes and bananas and some can make
poison and all those kinds of things and
we need to be able to we need to
consider
the the full
stack
of things that are constructed from the
fundamental basics
um and uh i guess iran you're saying
that no you
you're just like the theoretical
physicist it all starts at the bot like
if you need to preserve the fundamentals
of reality
uh which is the individual like the the
basic atom
of human society is the individual to
you so yes so the the basic unit the
basic model unit the basic ethical unit
in society is the individual and yeah of
course we form groups
and and you can't understand history
unless you understand group formation
and group motivation and
and and i have a view about what kind of
groups should be formed
uh and and politically from a political
perspective voluntary ones ones in which
we we join when we want to join and we
can leave when we want to leave and uh
ones that help us
and clearly groups help us
pursue
whatever it is a goal
is ultimately so so in the pursuit of
happiness there are lots of groups that
one wants to form
whether it's marriage whether it's
businesses
whether it's sports teams whether it's
lots of there's lots of different groups
going on the phone but but the question
is what is the standard of well-being is
it the standard well being some
algorithm that maximizes the well-being
of a group you know some utilitarian
function
you know is it uh
is it
something that's inherent in the group
that we can measure
as goodness and to hell with individuals
within as long as we can get that that
the group to function well we don't
really care about where the individuals
are so to me the the the the goal of
creating groups
is the well-being of the individual and
that's why it needs to be voluntary and
that's why there has to be a way out of
of those sometimes it's costly it's not
a cheap out that's why you should really
think about what groups you you you and
this you know on an issue that's very
controversial
maybe we can discuss maybe not this is
why to me immigration is so important
right open immigration or free
immigration is because that's another
group that i would like people to be
able to voluntarily choose both in and
out and and i'd like to see people be
able to go and join that group that
you know that they believe will will
allow for the pursuit of happiness but
let me say that you know
that's a description of an idea what i'm
just saying right i recognize that
that's not the reality in which we live
i recognize that that's not the reality
in which history history
you know recognizing that such a that
the individual exists in a sense
philosophically is a massive achievement
right
you know human beings however they
evolved clearly we started out
in in a in a tribal context in which the
individual didn't matter we followed the
leader the competition was for power
power over the group and and and
dictates how the group should work uh
you know it the the history of human
beings is a history of gaining knowledge
and part of the knowledge is
the value of an individual and and you
can see that in in in religion you can
see that in philosophy you can see that
uh through the evolution and then
you know uh
we we evolved from tribes into nations
and then
empires and conflicts between nations
and conflict within empires and we tried
a lot of different things if you will i
don't think we always did it on purpose
but uh we kind of did different
philosophies different sets of ideas
drove us towards different
collectives different groupings and and
different ways in which to structure
and after i don't know 3000 years of
kind of known history uh it's history
before that but we don't know much about
it 3000 years of known history you can
sit back and evaluate
and and i think that's what that's what
is done in the enlightenment and and you
sit back and suddenly we can do it today
we can sit back and evaluate what
promotes human flourishing and what
doesn't and what do we mean by human
flourishing human who's who's
flourishing well individual human beings
now
since i don't believe in a zero-sum
world and the world is not zero summit
we can see that it's it's empirically
possible to show that the world is not a
zero-sum game my fl human flavishing
doesn't come at your expense so i i you
know i can show that a system that
promotes my flourishing will probably
promote your flourishing as well and
promotes the general welfare in that
sense because it promotes
individuals
flourishing and we can we can look at
all these
examples of how we evolved and what
leads to bloodshed and what doesn't and
and and what promotes this ability to
flourish as an individual again an
achievement the idea of individual
flourishing
and then we can think about how to
create a political system around that a
political system
that recognizes and allows for the
formation of groups
you